Hello everybody and welcome back part 8 of Portal 2.
We are so close to the finale.
My voice today is okay, but I can't stop.
I feel like a...
It feels like something is in my throat.
So if I'm like...
A lie, I apologize.
But, um...
Last time, um...
I brain-blasted...
Through some of the...
I almost said through some of the portals.
But yes, I portaled.
And now I'm...
I've been kind of sitting and thinking about the last puzzle
that I ended off on.
So, um...
And I think I got some ideas when I was like, how can I
solve this?
So let's get back into it.
Wheatley.
Wheatley, you weirdo.
Wheatley the weirdo.
Look how cute they are.
Oh, okay.
So we are in chapter 8.
Puzzle 15.
Now I originally thought maybe I need to like, go and jump
down and launch to get this.
But I tried it a couple times and I feel like it's a little,
like, usually I feel the puzzles are, how do you say, like,
um, they're not so, like, trial and error in that kind of
sense, I feel.
You know what I mean?
Like, I feel like with that, it's, I don't know.
like i don't know so i feel like that's not the appropriate
way and i've been looking a lot or not looking but i was
thinking a lot about this section right because there's no
other reason for us to go over here except for getting the
cube so first i think our first order of business is to get
the cube and then our second order of business is to find
out how to spread the goo spread my goo so those are our two
things
but now i know one way that i moved the cube before was with
this guy i accidentally dropped him
If I...
It does go back this way.
Okay, wait.
I had it up here, right?
And then it'll...
And then if I...
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, over here.
Oh my god.
No.
Wait.
We got him!
We
got him!
Stick you right there, buddy.
Oh, no, don't fall off.
Don't fall off.
Is this the ammunition inside of him?
Oh my god, it really is.
Better...
Hoppy.
Okay, so now we have that and we have this.
But there's literally no...
There's literally no...
Okay, but I do think that this needs to be like here, right?
it does go through so what we probably do is run run run run
pew and then get caught and then go over there that's that's
what i had thought of from the beginning are you getting off
to this are you enjoying yourself i don't know he looks
unenthused maybe okay sorry i was just making sure i was
recording
and I can't get up here oh wait well that would make it wait
a second I can oh but I can't shoot through here oh wait how
do I get home uh oh oh I can get home they thought of this
oh my god they thought of it I thought I had just gotten it
but no there's no way that they wouldn't allow you to solve
it without using the gull.
Oh my god, I was like so close for a second though.
Wait, but it does pass through.
Do you think I can hold the gull?
Wait, is there stuff down here?
I'm curious.
We're exploring now.
Any secrets?
Can I get back up?
Wait, uh-oh.
Um, wait.
Okay, I have to die.
Okay.
Do you think it can hold the goo?
We haven't actually...
We never tried that before.
Oh my gosh, wait, it stopped right here!
The game is so kind!
Because, like, we haven't had...
Look, it passes right underneath.
We haven't had the teleport or not the teleport, whatever
this is called, plus goo.
before.
Oh wait, can I reach that?
Close enough?
Oh wait.
Oh, I think we need our friend.
I think we need this guy to maybe hold down the...
Instead of hold down that, he holds down this button.
Okay, friend.
Oh my gosh.
I feel so rested.
Okay, you.
You.
And then I stand on it.
Wait, I'm scared.
Okay, it probably...
He picks up the goo!
How far do I go?
As far as I want, baby.
It's...
Oh, oops.
More goo, please.
Please.
Okay, it does stop after a certain point.
Is this it?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, then we need our friend again.
You?
Oh my god.
There's some patches missing, but I think it's okay.
Maybe.
Okay.
Moment of truth!
Oh wait.
No, I'm a silly.
I'm a silly goose.
One moment.
We need a...
There.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh, okay, okay, okay.
Here we go.
You two are gonna love this big surprise.
In fact, you might say you're going to love it to death.
Gonna love it until you... until it kills you, until you're
dead.
Alright, I don't know whether you're picking up on what I'm
saying there.
Thanks, we get it.
Thanks, Wheatley.
Thank you.
I got an achievement.
I have mastered this thing.
Wow, I can't believe it picks up that girl.
That just opens up the world to a whole new world.
I think Wheatley might kill us.
I think that might be his idea.
I thought that I might be stuck on that for a little bit
longer but okay we're brain blasting we're brain blasting
we're back
to more goo let's go more goo okay just you wait a second
I'm sorry this man is getting off to us doing puzzles and
then splashes us with the white goo only three more chambers
to your big surprise
oh it's tiring what does this do oh this switches it okay we
have three little little turrets.
What else do we got going on in here?
Oh.
I died.
I did not realize the...
I did not realize that the wall did not go the whole way.
Okay, so they are searching me.
Oh my gosh, wait.
The place is literally on fire.
They are aiming at my head.
Very much so.
Ah!
He didn't mean to go through it.
But I did see there was another one on the other side.
Oh god, we're gonna have to listen to... Oh, there's one
right there.
Oh, sorry.
There's a button here, which...
Oh, opens up this.
Okay.
Ah, but how?
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I...
If I go up, though, they're going to get me, aren't they?
If I go up there, they're definitely going to attack me.
Let's see.
Oh, God.
It hurts.
Okay, this one might require some trial and error as I
continuously die.
Ignore Wheatley.
He's stupid.
Okay, that is not a portal.
Yeah, you're tiring.
I'm tired of you.
Now, what is this, though?
Yeah, you thought...
Actually, I don't know what they thought.
We got the bounce goo.
I think we need to do the same thing again somehow.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes, we need to do the same thing again with the bounce goo.
Oh, my depth perception!
I thought it was over top!
My bad.
I thought it was on top of the other area!
I really did.
That's pretty bad.
Oh, jeez.
What if I splat?
Oh, I can't splash them, I think.
Okay, three, two.
One.
Oh,
it falls through.
Wait, actually, I don't think I have a way of getting back.
I can bounce here though, I can bounce here.
Yeah.
And that will make it so that I can get back.
Uh oh, wait, they're gonna attack me.
Wait, they're gonna see me.
Wait, they're gonna attack me.
Oh, I'm in trouble.
I'm in trouble.
I'm in trouble!
Okay, okay, that's fine.
This is fine.
But all of this...
Okay, interesting.
How can I...
Kill them?
Is the big million...
Wait, I just realized the exit is over there!
I thought for some reason it was over there.
I'm going to go up in there.
Our big question is taking out these turrets.
I mean, it obviously is something involved, like, on this
side, right?
I think I need to, like, be there.
And very quickly, like, jump down.
take them out you know that's my hypothesis if I can get up
there without if I can here let's try from like back here
maybe okay they can't see me
ah oh wait is this tall enough I wonder if I like wait can I
okay
I definitely thought There would be more room behind them,
too.
To take them out.
That was so funny, wasn't it?
Wasn't it so funny?
Dang, I'll have to do that goo again.
But also...
I'm like thinking, is there a way to get the goo...
Elsewhere?
But once it's like here, there's no other thing.
to get it through, you know.
That was a test.
There was an attempt there.
I guess I didn't expect myself to land on the platform, so
that's what got me so flustered about it.
If I pick one up, I just gotta...
Maybe I gotta run in and pick them up real fast and take
them out.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can do it.
You can do it.
Me too.
Just eat.
I don't know if that's the solution.
Okay.
Oh,
sorry.
Ah!
Jeez, oh my gosh.
The bouncy goo does not get me up to here.
But we can go back over there.
Let's try.
Let's go back over there.
Wait.
Yeah, target lost.
Oh, that's right.
I like the little countdown it has.
Yeah, bouncy.
Where else can I get this goo?
Pretty addicting, though.
Oh, I was about to say, I wish it were like the white goo so
I could portal it.
What if...
Don't kill me.
Don't get me, don't get me, don't get me, don't get me,
don't get me.
Deploying!
Ooh!
Wait a second, I just realized I forgot about...
I completely forgot about this button.
Which makes it go the opposite way.
But I don't have...
Ah!
I forgot about this one.
Okay, wait.
But I don't have, like, a block to keep it on.
What we could do is launch it.
Wait, the goo.
Oh, wait, but how?
Okay, hold on.
When it switches, do you think the goo will disappear?
Because if we get the goo here, I come, how would I come
back?
Oh wait, I would come back via this, jumpy in this, and then
send it back through here and then send it back through here
wait this is so convoluted I mean it's worth a shot right I
have nothing else it's a little convoluted how did they see
me you didn't don't even lie all right go
my goo go deploy my goo deploy all All right, hopefully it
doesn't disappear.
There's several factors that need to work here for this
to...
For this to work.
Oh.
Maybe I need to be faster.
Yeah, okay, okay.
I think it will work.
I think I just need to be faster.
Okay, okay.
So as soon as I click it, I jumped.
And I go.
And then I watch it.
And then I turn it around.
And then I let it go through.
Turn around my goo.
Oh, it worked.
It worked.
Oh, my God.
And then we...
Something.
Oh, shoot.
And then...
We...
Oh my god, two of them!
Oh my god, oh my god, I might be a...
Oh my god, I might be a genius for real.
Okay, dang it, I missed the last guy.
But I think this is what we gotta do.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
I missed the last one.
Wow, that's so convoluted.
It's so stinking convoluted, but that's okay.
All right.
Alright, orange.
Blue.
Go and jump!
Don't get me.
Don't see me.
You don't see me.
You don't get me.
You don't got me.
You don't have me.
Okay.
And then...
Reverse!
And then I orange over here once it's through.
Orange!
Oh wow!
Like that, shoot, shoot, shoot.
And then...
Like, um...
Blue!
Yeah!
Oh my god, what a thrill.
And then that...
Allow us for a portal!
Okay.
Dang, I can't believe...
We did that!
And so...
That goes into the ceiling.
Yeah.
Huh.
Surely it doesn't want me to, like, bounce, bounce, right?
Surely not.
I thought it was going to be just an open...
No.
Why is it facing north?
Because if it wasn't, I could just...
La, la, la, la, all the way over there.
Don't get too close.
Too close.
Okay, second part.
Second part of the puzzle.
I think it wants me to bounce.
Or, like, fly and bounce.
That's what I think it wants me to do.
But where can I get so much momentum?
You know what?
Let's just try...
I do it like here.
yeah this is actually pretty tall right and then if I drop
I'm scared what if I miss oh
you sold it good good one good for you so he's inexplicably
happy
there what did he find back there oh god don't say Uh, it
was Metal Gear Rex.
Oh, no!
Aperture Laboratories is actually located on Shadow Moses
Island?
I'll bet you're both dying to know what your big surprise
is.
Well, only two more chambers.
Two more chambers.
We're running out of time.
I take
along.
Okay.
So there's definitely not going to be a boss fight with him,
right?
Because you're going to help us, right?
shadows.
Surprise!
We're doing it now!
Okay.
I found two little robots back here, built specifically for
testing.
Oh yeah, those guys.
He found the coil bridge a testing initiative.
Oh no.
It's something I came up with to phase out human testing
just before you escaped.
Oh shoot.
Why would you come up with that?
Yes, soldier.
You know, you did kill me.
There's fair.
Yeah, but I didn't kill you.
You're here right now.
Oh, aren't you?
This is the point where you kill someone.
No way, we're already here at the park where he kills us!
Ah!
There I was, smashing some steel plates together.
And I thought to myself, yeah, it's deadly.
But what's missing?
What's missing?
And I thought, lots of sharp bits welded onto the fragments.
It's still a work in progress, don't judge me yet.
But you know, eventually, I'd like to get them to...
No, no, no, no, no, no, don't do that.
Stand right here.
Stand, stand, stand, stand, stand, stand.
Stand, stand, stand.
Ha!
Oh, I can't jump to that.
I really...
underestimated my or overestimated my legs he even gave me a
way to portal there
oh my god the part where he kills us i can't believe we're
already here i thought that i actually had two more tests
smashing some steel plates together and i thought to myself
yeah it's deadly but what's missing what's missing and i
thought lots of sharp bits welded onto the fire yeah i see
them judge me yet um but you know eventually i'd like to get
them to sort of shoot fire at you um moments before no no no
no don't do that oh i did that okay where'd you go come back
come back no seriously come back please come back okay look
i've decided i'm not gonna kill you okay if you come back oh
just thinking back to the old times the old days when we
were friends good old friends Yeah, by the way, they've come
back.
What happened to those days?
Where?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude.
Where even can I portal to?
Wait.
Up there?
Maybe?
I just barely missed it.
It's gonna start me back at the running sequence, right?
Yeah.
Sorry.
what happened to those days oh yes this is where we started
oh i need to fling myself from there i believe yes i do do
believe where you're flinging myself to somewhere let's go
you can't help but notice now you're not coming back you're
just disappointed oh i've got an idea ah yes save your face
no i was gonna take you Fine.
Let the games begin.
No!
I was gonna take him!
Uh...
Got me not able to jump over a dang thing.
Please, sir.
You make this... The things are too high and my legs are
much too short.
Why did I think I could jump that?
I don't know.
Maybe I could jump this.
Oh!
What
happened to those days?
What happened to those days?
So true.
What happened to the days where I'm crashing under the
pressure?
I really was prepared for two more tests.
He got me good.
I got completely bamboozled.
Look at this poor little creature.
He's so cute.
No!
Oh my gosh.
This is so sad.
All right, how do I jump?
Why am I so stupid?
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
I believe right there.
Maybe a little further down.
Give me some leeway.
Oh, my God.
Why am I so bad at this?
I'm...
Sabotaging myself.
The very end.
I love the music when you fly around.
I've got an idea.
Yes!
In your face, I got Marvin.
Fine.
Let the games begin.
Begin.
I... I don't... I... Guys?
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I can't make this.
Can I crouch jump?
Why am I so stupid?
You don't think I could just jump the thing, right?
No, there's no way I could just jump over across the thing.
It was way too long.
You're not coming back.
back because i don't i'm stupid i think i think i'm dumb i
think i'm like so stupid really i might be one of you
poor guy poor guy i'm so stressed about this i thought i
lived for a second
Wait, so, is this my last part then?
Wow.
I thought I would have nine parts.
Okay, all right, hold on.
I've got an idea.
Yeah, me too.
No, I actually don't have an idea.
How am I supposed to make this?
Yes, yes, in your face, I got...
This is the only part that I can do.
Besides, like, here, but I can't jump on that.
You know?
Do I need to, like, run and do it while it's, like, crushed?
I wonder?
Am I just being too slow?
Even the music is starting to calm down.
I wonder if it's...
Maybe while I'm falling, I can like portal in and like, you
know...
The game's like, nah, girl, what are you doing?
Okay, I'm gonna run.
Why am I stuck at this one part?
This is so stupid.
Um...
Okay, I'm gonna like...
Have it already set up.
Yes, yes, in your face, I got armor.
Fine, let the games begin.
We destroyed it!
Oh, gosh.
Guys, why am I so stuck on this part?
Is it, like, a little over, maybe, that I need to go?
Okay.
I can't jump here.
What the hell is wrong with me?
Maybe, like, a little over more.
I didn't know this was a platforming game.
The part where he kills me, except I keep killing myself.
If I
am portaled there.
Wait, okay, maybe I set it up, right?
Okay, hold on, maybe I have the right idea.
For real.
I don't know.
I was so big-brained that the other things what happened to
me.
Ah!
Doesn't it work?
What happened to those days?
Okay.
It is disappointing.
Oh!
I've got an idea!
Yes!
Save your face!
Please!
Oh no!
Fine.
Let the games begin.
No.
I thought I orangeed.
Are you kidding me?
You guys, I had it.
Okay, orange first, then blue.
What happened to those days?
Orange first, then blue, orange first, then blue.
I come in, I orange.
Then...
I run over.
Then I blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue!
Ah!
What happened to those days?
This is the part where he kills you, and this is the part
where she rages.
Can't help but notice that you're not coming back.
You're just disappointed.
Oh, oh, God, I did.
Yes, yes, in your face, I got lost.
Fine.
It sounds like the part where he's disappointed is the part
where I fall, and he's disappointed that I fall.
Fall to those days.
Fall to my death.
Really?
I don't like this part!
Let me try from here.
Really?
Can't you just kill me?
Can't you just kill me instead?
Oh, I've got an idea!
Yes, yes, save me your face.
I've got time.
Fine.
What happened to those days?
Can't help but notice.
Nah, you're not coming back.
Which is disappointing.
Oh, I've got an idea.
Yes, yes, save me your face.
I've got time.
Okay.
Almost there.
Don't mind me.
Continuous daily.
Oh!
This is a portable booboo booboo!
Oh.
Yeah, I knew it.
Okay, yes, it's a
trap.
What?
We'll go through?
Oh.
Ha!
Oh my god, my stupid turrets!
They are killing you.
They are killing you, aren't they?
Live ammunition.
Silently killing you.
Probably.
Yeah, hi buddies!
This one's not even real.
That would explain the extremely quiet killing that I'm
hearing.
Look, I can have one in my room!
But not dead.
Stomp once.
If you're dead, there's obviously no stomp.
And two stomp if you're not dead.
Was that your bullet riddled body flying out the room?
Those were the crap turrets, weren't they?
Yeah.
Did you just call them the crap turrets?
It's so mean.
all the cards and guess what they're all full houses they're
actually played cards meaning to learn anyway new turrets
not defective ace of fours the best hand unbeatable i would
imagine can i get in there i'm going underneath them they
have no clue i'm beneath their nose oh shoot right no no no
no no no no no no okay
Let's see.
Oh, shoot.
No!
I get lost.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
No!
Oh, no.
Everything's not fine.
Sometimes it's fine.
Sometimes it's not fine at all.
Okay.
Maybe...
Ouch!
Oh, I died!
That's okay.
I know how to get rid of each little one of their bodies.
Those were the crap turrets, weren't they?
Yeah.
Well, no matter, because I'm still holding all the cards.
And guess what?
They're all full houses.
They're actually playing cards, meaning to learn.
Anyway, new turrets, not defective.
Okay,
that's one down.
Two down.
Ouch!
Okay, critical error.
Oh,
we couldn't save the last guy.
So sad, so sad.
So if I go this way...
What's here anyway?
Oh, a bunch of goo.
And, uh...
Oh, wow.
Where am I supposed to go?
Is there something in there?
Oh, I see.
Clever.
Very clever.
Oh, the goo.
And foolish.
Spinning blade wall.
I hear Melia.
Look.
Well, good, good.
What if I just let it happen?
You know?
What's going on in here now?
What is going on in here now?
I guess we'll just, uh, go this way and find out.
Find out.
Holmes versus Moriarty.
Aristotle versus Mashew Spike Plays.
It won't get me, right?
Oh!
I thought it was a one-time use.
Oh,
I see it now.
Stay still, please.
All right, stop moving.
Oh, almost going there.
Almost going there.
Oh, shoot!
Oh!
I thought I wasn't gonna make it for a second.
We're not gonna make it!
Oh, he doesn't even know.
Where'd you go?
Come back!
Stupid head.
Oh!
Of course it was- oh!
Nice!
Good!
Oh, oh, did it kill you?
That would be amazing if it killed you.
What's going on in there?
Help!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yes, just had a brain wave.
I'll be back.
If you're still alive, I'm going to be back.
Don't die until I get back.
That's a lot of guys.
Oh, holy cow.
What the hell is going on here?
What's this do?
What is it do?
Activates.
Oh, the...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Does that...
Yeah!
Take them out one by one!
A little lower.
A little over.
Yeah!
A little higher?
Can we get much higher?
Very good.
He's still...
Oh, they're still bouncing around.
It's so funny.
I heard something explode.
Whoever that was, I sound good, I think.
Now I need to get over there and...
Oh, there's a whole...
Okay, there's that there.
Wee!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
We don't need to get over there at all.
Oh, Wheatley's not even around.
He's taking a nap.
Lazy bum.
I'm solving all your puzzles.
Well, I guess I should try and finish the game in this part,
huh?
Even though it might be a little bit longer.
Crashing's too good for him.
incinerator year two cryogenic refrigeration wing then 10
years in the chamber i built to
kill him nice all right so we got white goo going on what
does this do
oh what is that oh lovely wait are we Now, how can I utilize
that?
Do I blow this up?
Because at the current state of things, I cannot get over
there.
So let's try this and this and have it blow up the white
goo.
not me though right
nice okay I like how it just stops doesn't even attempt to
like
what's in here doesn't even attempt to like keep going it's
like nah I think I'll shut down now I think I'm good
we're back to test ish tests asterisk now I wish this is
where I wish I had you guys around because I'm like how much
further do I have of the game because I could finish it if
it but if it's like oh no it seems like you're in the last
chapter but it's another hour then it's like you know I
don't want to the next part being 10 minutes though either
let's see it
I know that is a portal to Boulogne.
Okay, I thought as soon as I jumped down here, it would
start sending me to the spike, so...
Oh.
Let's get rid of this.
Ah.
I knew it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
There we go.
I wanted to talk to you for a moment, if I may.
Oh, sure!
I'm honest.
The death traps have been a bit of a failure.
A little bit.
Yeah.
I think you'll agree.
You are getting very close to my lair.
Lair.
It's weird that first time I've said that and now it turns
out to be ridiculous really.
But I can assure you it is one, it is a proper lair, deadly
lair.
And I just wanted to give you the chance to kill yourself
now before you get to the lair.
I could just jump into that masher just there.
That's a death trap or a death option for you.
Sounds crazy, but hear me out, hear me out.
Once you get to my lair, death will not happen.
be optional all right it will be mandatory no tricks no
surprises just you dying as a result of me killing you in a
very very gruesome way so book better offer here is just
kill yourself you know what are you asking me to do lately
oh shoot your death would be entirely voluntary and very
much appreciated the match it does work i should point out
as well i know we've got a couple of problems um in the past
this match works and it will kill you if that's one of your
concerns about not jumping in okay i'll take that as a no
then oh oh oh and this sounds like a boss music
whoa what has he done to this place we wow it's yellow that
can't be the sun right oh those are explosions in there
sometimes it appears that there are little mines in here?
Okay, so what do we got going on over here?
We got ourselves a portal.
We don't want to go back to that death trap.
We're going to go to the other death trap.
Can I...
Get this?
Dispute?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then if we do this...
Yeah, okay, here we go.
Oh, I made it!
Oh.
Is this?
What?
This is...
This is definitely boss music.
You know, I'm not stupid.
I realize you don't want to put me back in charge.
Well...
I think I'll betray you.
And on any other
life voice.
Oh.
I'm being serious.
I think there's something really wrong with me.
Oh, Gladys.
I kind of missed when you insulted me, though.
Ooh.
I didn't realize.
that would be a place to load.
Yes, that's where I had that.
Oh, oh!
Oh, thank goodness there's no fall damage in this game, huh?
Oh, there we go.
To him.
If we do it a few times, he might become corrupt enough for
another core transfer.
They're freaky, huh?
I like this guy.
This one looks pretty mellow.
This one looks like...
I think they were inspired by Ichiwawa.
I like the...
When did we start making...
When did we start making bombs?
What's that meme?
Oh, we're making bombs now.
Hold on, I'm gonna save.
Oh no, I'm getting into, like, the Bioshock of it all.
Even though this game is not really like that.
But, you know...
all right they're like hey buddy remember you got you got
goose and you got you got bombs let's go oh are you gonna
give me one oh okay wait no glados i just want to say before
you go heartfelt music play that i really enjoyed our time
together and i do I miss that you insult me, but I also like
you as my little potato friend.
Okay, I'm plugging you.
Look, even if you think we're still enemies, we're in
revenge.
Revenge, baby.
Yeah.
Everybody likes revenge.
Well, let's go get some.
Woohoo!
Oh.
Well, well, well, welcome.
We're here!
Giving us flag something up.
According to the control panel light up there, the entire
building is going to self-destruct in about six minutes.
Six minutes.
sure it's a problem with the light i think the light's on
the plate but just in case it isn't i am actually gonna have
to kill you um as discussed earlier so let's call that three
minutes and then a minute break but we should leave
allegedly two minutes to figure out how to shut down
whatever is starting all the fires right that's the
itinerary also i took the liberty of watching the tapes of
you killing her and i'm not going to make the same mistakes
four part plan is this one no portal services two start the
neurotoxin immediately oh shoot Leading the right deal to
number four, four.
Throwing in you.
You know what?
This plan is so good.
I'm gonna give you a sporting chance and turn off the
neurotoxin.
Oh, I'm stuck in there.
Of course.
Goodbye.
Neurotoxin level at capacity in five minutes.
Alright, so I need...
Woo!
Come on!
Yeah!
Don't run!
No, no, no!
We're here.
The harder you breathe, the more neurotoxin you'll care.
Wait, can you like shoot them at me again?
No!
Ah!
There we go.
That sounded real, no.
That was actually an impression of you.
Actually, because you just fell into my trap by bringing a
trap.
Oh my gosh.
Ah, where is the blue girl?
Oh my gosh, okay, hold on.
Because that needs overconfidence.
And that needs mistakes.
That's all part of the plan.
Ah, but that.
Wait, hold on, maybe I like...
Alright, if I can have it...
Ouch!
Ow!
Okay, I was gonna have it like launch back out of.
Okay, okay, first we gotta obviously do the goo.
Oh, oh, okay.
Couch.
Oh my gosh.
You trick me, seemingly trick me, to give you false hope.
False hope.
Because that leads to overconfidence.
And that leads to mistakes.
They all mistakes.
And it's all part of the plan.
But, I have actually made my actual first mistake by telling
you my...
I wish I could tell where they land.
Or I do it like...
There instead, right?
I imagine you won't even use...
I got him!
Oh my god, I got him!
Oh, it worked.
Uh, stun him, stun him.
Okay, ah, shoot.
Space, space, space.
Space, space.
Go to space.
Oh, holy cow.
Oh my god.
How do I attach it to him?
Wait, how do I attach it to him?
Oh, there it is.
Space, I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go to space.
Ugh!
Wait, I can't jump!
Okay, hold on.
Wait!
Wait, I thought that was a jump.
Wait, no?
Okay, jump here.
Why is the jump so bad?
Ugh!
Why can't I jump?
I'm trying!
I'm not playing in space.
You're in space, dear.
I can't!
Space!
Shut up!
There we go.
Okay.
Warning.
Core corruption at 50%.
Neurotoxin offline.
Reactor explosion in four minutes.
Oh, nice.
The neurotoxin's off, though.
What happened?
What, what, what, what do you, what do you call to me?
What is that?
Hold on.
Ah, the bloody bombs are stuck on.
Doesn't matter.
I've reconfigured the shields.
Oh, it's a quarry upon me.
Who told you to do that?
Oh, maybe here.
It's just making me stronger.
Maybe like underneath.
Oh, come on!
Is there one that's open?
win.
Woo!
You know what?
I think we're well past the point of tasteful restraint.
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Okay, I guess that's not it, huh?
It doesn't even...
This one's tough.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
I can't aim.
I'm not Kobe.
And you didn't, did you?
Oh, you remember that?
I remember that.
I remember that all the time.
Oh, my God.
Tell me that you murdered her and that she needed you to
live.
So the only available venue for her raid would be good old
crushable.
Oh, I got him.
Okay, good.
Alright.
Next one.
Hey!
Oh, I- What's the situation?
Hey, how you doing?
Oh my god, are you kidding me right now?
What?
Are you fighting that guy?
Oh, crazy!
Oh my god.
I think I need to...
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I'm stressed.
I'm stressing a little bit.
I don't want to scare you.
I'm an adventurer.
Please!
No!
Ah!
You stand behind me.
Yeah, just like that.
Just like you're doing.
Things are about to get real messy.
Hoi!
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
Yeah, I got him.
Okay.
You're right here.
Man, that clock is moving fast.
Yeah, I know.
You are beautiful.
Hoi!
Thank you.
Warning.
Core corruption at 75%.
Oh!
Reactor explosion uncertainty, emergency preemption protocol
initiated.
This facility will self-destruct in two minutes.
I told you not to put these cores on.
But you don't listen, do you?
Oh!
Quietly.
Not listening to a word I say, judging.
Excited.
Worst.
All I wanted to do was make everything better for you.
All you had to do was to solve a couple of hundred simple
tests.
Dang it.
They're like, it's behind him.
It's behind him.
Oh, I got him!
Whoa, that was so close.
That was so close.
Holy cow.
I did it.
All right, which one is it?
Where's this one at?
Uh, Lados?
Lados, where is it?
Oh.
What?
What am I supposed to- Okay, uh, shoot.
Uh, maybe like that.
Oh, that's not at all.
I thought what happened.
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
I'm pausing real quick.
I'm stressing out.
Ah, I only have a minute.
Okay, I just need a second to breathe.
Okay.
It's right there.
I don't think this grabs it though.
Where is she?
I can't even see.
Oh no, it's, it's, uh, shoot.
I'm gonna have to redo this, I think.
I don't want to redo the whole fight though.
But this fight, it's not so bad.
I'm not gonna lie, it's not so bad.
I'm just, I'm just stressing right now.
I can't stop pausing.
Okay, calm down, calm down.
I'm stressing.
I don't like countdowns.
I don't like timers.
Let me do it at my own minto pace, you know.
Okay.
I'm doing, like, every single meditative activity I have on
my desk.
Okay.
I know I have to run, but to wear.
like
i have to grab it first oh wait maybe i grab it like this
okay
i don't know i don't know i think i have to run and do that
here that's where i my order of operations is wrong, but I
can't grab it.
I don't know how to grab it.
Oh, it's going to self-destruct.
That's okay.
You are about to get me killed.
I'm sorry!
Ah.
Okay, I know how to do it now.
This facility will self-destruct in two minutes.
Enough!
I told you not to put these cores on it, but you don't need
to do it!
What?
Ah!
How do I get her?
How do I get it?
Oh,
I can't even...
Oh, yes, I can.
Wait!
There is no blue around...
around here.
How do I get her?
How do I get...
I don't know.
At least, you know, the game is very nice.
I don't have to do much of anything like this.
How do I get you?
The automobile brake was not invented as an 1895.
Before this, someone had to remain in the car at all times,
driving in circles until passengers returned from their
heavens.
Greetings, our subconscious mind's way of reminding people
to go to school naked and have their teeth blocked.
Yeah, like, this makes it so that I can get the thing on.
How do I get the core itself?
How do the name, Tesla Science?
Hands were invented by Sailors in the 16th century.
How do I get you?
It was believed that the sight of naked sailors angered the
sea got.
This one's just gets dumping...
It's not like... I don't think I can jump...
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump?
I'll try that.
I'll try jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump...
Jump, jump, jump, maybe.
Because there has to be a reason for it.
that well i don't know this facility will self-destruct in
two minutes enough i told you not to put these cores on but
you don't listen what don't listen oh i'm listening but
listening to a word i say judge it sign it works out all i'm
going to do is make everything better quickly all you have
to do Oh!
Oh!
Got him.
Jump!
Alright, we'll wait for her to come out.
I don't get
enough!
I don't get enough!
Ah!
Maybe I can jump here.
Actually, let me try that.
Wait.
Oh!
Uh...
Maybe I don't need to run now.
Okay, okay, okay, hold on.
Uh...
I just need to get air.
I just need to...
Maybe here?
Oh my god!
I have way to get rid of radioactivity.
Ah!
I just need a...
We'll have way the kid too!
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I just need a way to get to here!
From high up!
What the fuck?
Jump!
Ah!
Benjamin Hillary, the first person to find Mount Everest,
did so accidentally while chasing a bird.
The whales are twice as intelligent and three times as
delicious as humans.
During the Great Depression, the Tennessee Valley Authority
outlawed cat rats, forcing many to hunt blue-gut long ears
onto their catnaps.
William Shakespeare did not-
This facility will self-destruct in two minutes.
do not to put these corners on them, but you don't listen,
do you?
Quiet.
Oh, to be quietly, not listening to a word I say, judgment,
to be silent, worsen.
All I wanted to do was make everything better for you.
All you had to do was to solve a couple of simple tests for
a few years, and you couldn't even let me have that, could
you?
Gotta give us space.
Yeah, not a bunch of space.
Nobody's going to space, mate.
You never see.
You never call me.
I told that!
Use that on the core.
This fight should do it.
The
right foot is embedded in the airway.
Anyone wanting to fly anywhere was required to eat 200
pounds of meat.
At some point their lives, one in six children will be
abducted by the Dutch.
If you have trouble with simple food, use the following
demonic advice.
One, trunks before two.
Trunks before 60.
Trunks after 12.
Trunks before 63.
Trunks after 500 fold.
This will make your warrior counting difficulty.
Seen like no big deal.
The automobile brake was not implemented until 1895.
Before this, someone had to remain in the car at all times,
driving in circles until passengers returned for their
errands.
Yet the bus has superb tensile strength.
The moon orbits the Earth every 27 to 33 days.
In Victorian England, a commoner was not allowed to look
directly at the Queen, due to a belief in the times that the
poor had the ability to steal bombs.
Science now would be reckless that a 4% of poor people are
able to do this.
The first commercial airline took to the air in 1940.
screaming the entire way.
Katie's comic can be viewed orbiting Earth every 76 years.
For the other 75, they retreat to the heart of the sun,
where it hibernates undisturbed.
Marine Curie defended the theory of radioactivity, the
treatment of radioactivity, and dying from radioactivity.
In fact, space does not exist.
It was the invention of Scrabble Day in 1912.
The typical breakfast was either 4K, still in the ship, or
Scrabble runs.
It is incorrectly noted that Tom
This facility will self-destruct in two minutes.
Enough!
I told you not to put these cores on.
But you know this is doing it.
What?
Here's how the core.
This one should do it.
Tans were invented by sailors in the 16th century to avoid
Poseidon's wrath.
It was believed that the sight of naked sailors angered to
see God.
The first commercial airliners took to the air in 1914.
Everyone involved screened the entire weapon.
William Shakespeare did not exist.
How the hell am I supposed to get it?
I don't know.
Maybe like this.
for killing cats.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
In Victorian England, a commoner was not allowed to look
directly at the queen, due to a belief that the poor had the
ability to steal thoughts.
Science now believes that less than 4% of poor people are
able to do this.
Ah!
Manual core replacement required.
Oh, I see.
Substitute core.
Are you ready to start?
come on corrupted core are you ready to start what do you
think interpreting vague answer as yes oh no no no no get me
up on my sarcasm stalemate detected fire detected in the
stalemate resolution annex extinguishing oh very nice it's
fire and it just cleans right off does it well that would
have been good to know a little earlier oh no please press
the stalemate resolution button okay you're back just go
crazy Where's the button?
Oh, it's over there.
No!
Do not do it!
I can't bid you to press it!
I'm gonna press it!
I'm gonna press...
I need to get in there.
No!
Do not press that button!
Do not do it!
I'm gonna press it!
Ouch!
What?
Are you still alive?
You are joking?
Oh my god, we survived.
I'm still in control, and I have no idea how to fix this
place.
Oh, you have to play bloody...
What's happened?
I just portaled the moon.
Whoa!
Oh!
Ah!
What?
We're in space?
Let's go!
We're in space!
Peace!
Ah!
Let go!
I'm still connected!
I can pull myself in!
I can still fix this!
I already fixed it.
And you are not coming back!
Change your plans!
Hold on to me!
Tighter!
Run me!
Goodbye, Wheatley!
Oh my god!
Wait, how did we survive?
My angel!
She pulled me in!
Ah, no, she could have let us die!
Oh!
She's alive!
Lunacy, that just happened is the achievement I just got.
Holy hell.
Oh, thank God you're all right.
You know, being Carolyn taught me a valuable lesson.
She was Carolyn.
I thought you were my greatest enemy, but all along you were
my best friend.
The surge of emotion that shot through me when I saved your
life taught me an even more valuable lesson.
my brain caroline delete what goodbye caroline oh you know
the meeting caroline just now taught me a valuable lesson
the best solution to a problem is usually the easiest one
and i'll be honest killing you is hard you know what my days
used to be like i just tested nobody murdered you I'm so
glad she stays evil.
Or fed me to birds.
I had a pretty good life.
And then you showed up.
You dangerous mute lunatic.
So you know what?
You win.
Just go.
Oh.
It's been fun.
Don't come back.
Oh my god, I'm so glad she stays evil.
I was like about to be scared that we were gonna have a
good...
Lado's Ark.
No!
No way.
Oh.
Cube!
Companion Cube!
What was that?
That looks like monstrous.
Oh.
Our chorus.
Oh my god, the egg.
Giant!
Kiaru!
Turret King!
Queen!
Why is this making me emotional?
All the jungly stuff we went through.
It's actually outside.
Whoa.
Wheatfield.
Oh!
What an...
Oh my god!
A companion!
What an unassuming little shed.
Whoa!
Notice of dismissal.
It's always such a pleasure.
Remember when you tried to kill me twice?
Oh, how we laughed and laughed Oh, I laughing, yeah Except I
wasn't laughing Under the circumstances I've been shockingly
nice You want your freedom Take care
That was so good I feel stupid That I didn't get that one
part Trying to I was so stuck Sometimes you get so stuck on
thinking what you You think you know what the answer is but
it's not the right one you know and so in my brain i was
like and then let's just spill my tea
little caroline
so she lives on in the jungles of aperture
Gabe Nuhl!
He's in the credits.
Could I'm my only friend?
Oh, did you think I meant you?
Oh.
Would be funny if it weren't so sad.
Well, you have been replaced.
I think I've called out way too easily.
Maybe I'll stop feeling so bad.
Redact.
Kid Johnson.
Use of their face.
God.
Photo credit of Earth, NASA.
I can't believe Wheatley actually went to space.
So much space.
Need to see it all.
I wish I could take it all back.
I honestly do.
I could take it all back and not just because I'm stranded
in space.
I'm in space.
I know you are.
Yeah, we're both in space.
I'm in space.
Anyway, you know, if I was ever to see her again, do you
know what I'd say?
I'm in space.
I'd say I'm sorry.
Sincerely.
I am sorry.
I was bossy and monstrous and I am genuinely sorry.
I'm in space.
The end.
I don't really believe that he's in space you guys he's in
space
wow that was so good hello why is it hello do I click
something hello
that was so good did my game crash
I hope you guys enjoyed my portal to playthrough.
There were some parts that they tripped me up quite well.
They did.
I got frustrated.
I beat myself up a little bit over stuff.
But in the end, we made it.
I don't know why that last core, I think it's just, you
know, the stress of the countdown makes your brain really
freeze up.
But hello?
What's wrong with my game?
Oh.
That's it?
Wait, that's really it.
If I return to the game, nothing happens.
The end, he said.
The end.
Even if I walk around, jump.
Nothing.
Menu is Wheatley in space.
And Core 1 in space.
That was so fun.
I'm going to be thinking about Portal.
I just love puzzle stuff so much, you know.
I love puzzle games.
So I'm going to be thinking about this for quite some time,
I think.
Oh, that was so fun.
Portal 3 win, please.
I need more.
it was so fun I can't just stop saying it was so fun it's
just so it felt so fresh compared to the first game and I
love the lore behind everything like I love that aperture is
just this like crazy huge like oh my god you can't even you
can't even realize the scope of the place it's so and then
going back and doing like the tests from like the 60s that
was so fun seeing like kind of the olden days of aperture
and see watching uh watching oh my gosh what's his name that
guy has his like development as he started oh sorry my brain
cave johnson cave mr cave and how he was just like i'm a i'm
a guy with a spark for science and you guys are testing and
then he becomes this like he's like bring in the subjects
his development
so cool so so cool and i like that glados is still evil and
just once wanting to do tests and it's so funny what are the
tests even for what is this all
It's so cool though.
It's so cool!
I want more portal.
I will try and do the co-op.
With somebody.
Someday in the future.
I have done it before, but now that I have all this portal
to knowledge.
It was so cool seeing them at the end and everything.
I want to see if they like, like I said, I played it before,
but I don't remember how it went exactly.
there's like uh any more crossover that i didn't notice when
i played the co-op before so yeah yeah yeah thank you guys
so much i i wonder which song i like more i think i i think
still alive is iconic you know this was a triumph is like
the it's so iconic you know but i like the second song too
um Tundere for me, maybe.
Not maybe.
She's very Tundere for me.
So good.
Thank you guys for finishing Portal 2 with me.
And I hope you enjoyed it as much as I did.
I had so much fun.
We big brained on some of these.
And like I said, I got tripped up on some of them.
But that's just how it goes.
Sometimes your brain just refuses to see the the solution.
Especially like I said, when you get kind of focused, you
get tunnel vision, right, on like how you think the puzzle
needs to get done and it doesn't allow you to see the
broader stuff, right?
Like you're just kind of like, this is how it must be done.
And just because I'm doing it over and over and over again,
it's because of me, I'm doing it wrong.
But it's really just because I'm doing it wrong because it's
not the thing to do.
But I imagine a lot of these
puzzles.
Like for the first one that I did in this part, when I was
first trying to like launch myself to the pad, I imagine
that's possible.
You know, right?
Like there's somebody that has probably done it before.
But the solution that I did was much easier.
But I kind of like that.
Like it's, it's, there's freedom, but also there's, you
know, how they, not assume, how they set up the puzzle for
you that you know you have different ways of solving it
potentially you know that was so fun that was so fun oh
thank you guys so so much otamito otu portal 2
oh man this was a triumph it was so fun otamito everyone
thank you so much have a good day have a good night have a
good time you when i see you next bye bye bye bye